22e édition des journées du patrimoine
avec jusqu'à demain soir plus de quinze
mille sites ouverts au public l'occasion
de partir pour l'alsace à la découverte
de la cave des hospices civils de
strasbourg fondée au 14e siècle
on peut visiter ce monument depuis
seulement quelques années
dominique team bac l agente et repassera
l'hôpital civil de strasbourg les
auspices de la ville comme on disait
tout moyen-âge sa cave recèle parmi les
plus vieux vins d'alsace un patrimoine
que certains ont voulu découvrir en
famille c'est des vins qui sont très
anciens très avec une histoire
pour les enfants c'est leur manière les
manières leur faire découvrir qu'il ya
des choses à voir partout et se laisser
surprendre du vin dans un hôpital cela
peut surprendre en effet mais à l'époque
ce sont les malades eux mêmes qui ont
confié aux hospices le fruit de leur
labeur
s'il n'avait pas d'argent mais ils
paient que ce qu'ils arrivent donc il
donnait carrément un morceau de terrain
ou un morceau un carré de vigne
il faut aussi le clou de la visite un
vin 2472
le plus vieux au monde encore concerné
en plus un arôme fort boisé le négus
enfants du xvème siècle c'est un rêve
mais rien de lui mais je trouve que
c'est extraordinaire c'est comme un rêve
déjà et on n'a pas vraiment j'ai plus
envie de goûter parce que j'ai
l'impression d'avoir déjà découvert tout
un monde comme ça c'est vraiment un
c'est extraordinairement un moment
d'autant plus émouvant que l'un des
derniers à avoir goûté à ce breuvage et
le général leclerc la libération de la
ville en 1944 un patrimoine que même nos
voisins britanniques nous envie mais
sans vraiment le dire bien sûr la façon
de faire la différence des façons de
faire il est très intéressante et alors
qu'ils conservent le mieux son
patrimoine où je vais pas vous fait pas
peur je vais pas et meurent c'est une
préférence
l'année dernière 1700 personnes ont
visité la cave des hospices de
strasbourg
derrière ces voûtes le passé demeure
vivant